hi i'm gina ljubljana I'm one of the
executive producers on rock in a hard
place I'm also playing the role of cat
which has prizms girlfriend now who is
cat what is her sort of architect that
is a tomboy sec siliceous butch vegan
lesbian i can relate to so much about
her she's she's really powerful
strong-willed tends to be aggressive a
little controlling over her woman but
she really is is invested in prizm and
they have a very loving relationship
just super passionate and full of life
and she's a strong advocate for animals
that's really what she's living her life
for she's she's they have a company
together and they're doing a lot of
philanthropic work all around animals so
in this particular scene prizms father
shows up and I believe he's the guy from
the shelter so I'm shoving all these
boxes into his hands like this one's
vegan this one's this you know don't
mess him up and it just so happens that
it's her dad coming to see her for the
first time in many years so it's just
surprise to both of us yeah she and
Rehab know he Lynn Jones who they're
calling Lawrence now he's been in rehab
for years and he's really been ma-maa
from my girlfriend prizms life and I
could see the pain and the struggle that
it's caused for her so I kind of have
stepped up and I've been playing that
role for her she picked me because I
have a lot in common with her father so
much so that we kind of were wearing the
same clothes when he rolled up we had
the same leather jacket the same jeans
the same same energy same vibe so she
basically picked a partner that was like
her father which is sort of an eye true
to life so yeah I think they're just
madly in love and my character
really wants to be man I mean she's been
struggling and grappling with her
femininity and the masculine sides of
her and I think throughout the series we
will see her actually transform and make
her dreams come true and transform into
the man that she's always wanted to be
so it's definitely been an exploration
for me and a huge voyage this character
so did you come on as an actor first or
producer you know it's interesting I
came on as an actor first David Fagan
who's the writer creator and Stephanie
Fagan they had just seen an episode of a
show called The Mentalist that I did and
they approached me to play the role of
prism and I was so excited about it at
first I thought you know it's just like
another submission that I was receiving
online about like hey I just saw your
work you can check out this piece I
watched the teaser and I was really
blown away by it it just was a rock and
cool idea and so I asked David if he had
other producers attached yet and he said
no we're really in the beginning phases
it's like five years ago and so they had
just written and rewritten and gotten
the script for they wanted it to be and
I was one of the first people they had
reached out to cast so I said look I'm
I'm you know producing now I'm much more
interested in being involved on the
production side of projects that I'm
working on and would you guys be
interested in having me he said
absolutely he flew in from New York
we had a great long chat and I took it
and ran with it I first got us place
with Brett Ratner's company rat TV and
Showtime we were over there for quite
some time and it was a big deal we were
all excited you know I got the press
release the deadline Hollywood and all
that stuff hell we're doing with rat TV
and I guess Showtime really wanted Brett
Ratner to direct it and he was just
willing to be the exact producer he
didn't want her direct so then that deal
fell apart so then talk about
resurrection you know I just I brought
it to everyone I brought a tear in
Sorkin I brought it to Randy Jackson's
production company I brought it to mark
Berg's company then we landed over at e1
television
another friend of mine and that was
really exciting and that brought us some
really cool connections so far but that
that didn't end up going as well so you
know sometimes these projects have nine
lives and you really just have to keep
you know keep at it and chipping away at
it and and then the exciting thing was
that I I had written in the process of
waiting I had written a pilot for a
series myself and I went to like a
television pitch meeting and I met
Archie Gibbs who is connected with 44
blue Mark Wahlberg's company and he said
you know do you have anything you want
to pitch and I said yeah I do
so I pitched my show steely and Jack's
to him and he loved it and said you know
stop doing this on your own
because we were just about to film with
James call him fasiq the director I
always get I hired him to direct my
piece and when Archie read it he said
you know I'd really like to be involved
and co-write this with you rewrite it
and I'd like to direct so I called off
the production we were only a few wait a
few weeks away from shooting it and I've
been rewriting out with Archie so I
brought Archie and on this project as
well because this one was more fully
it was just ready it was round it was it
had been rewritten several times and he
really connected with the material and
said you know I'd like to jump in so
Archie came on board and last minute
couldn't direct because his wife just
had a baby so last minute I hired James
because you know he's super prolific 23
years old it was already done 30 plus
project so I thought he could handle the
time constraints and everything that was
going on so I think we got really lucky
so you stayed with this project a rock
and a hard place for five oh my goodness
I you know through thick and through
thin because it got really challenging
sometimes you know through the process
of writing and recreating and
reinventing things happen and other
projects have been coming up and I had
other world
and I a few times I thought you know I
might not stay with it because it was
taking so long and there are a few
losses and I felt defeated a few times
but then I had invested so much time and
energy and I really believed in it so I
was like you know what it's I know it's
gonna happen just stay put stay focused
don't give up and here we are so you
know for me it was it's really been a
great exercise and hanging in there and
you know tenacity and persistence and
patience really are you a person that
loves to stay busy all the time yes
super a type I've got like five things
whole going local influence she's the
best she's the best guys are awesome
this crew has been the cast and the crew
has just been so phenomenal I don't
think we could have gone any luckier
especially again with the time
constraints because some of it has just
been throw together even though it's
been five years we kind of got thrust
into this you know the original director
having a POV and having to hire someone
new our first two days we lost two cast
members I had to recast one of my best
friends in the role of prism so it's
just been very interesting I think you
might have already interviewed Sheldon
who had to take from the place of Tony
Rock so it's been there's been some
bumps and hurdles but I think it's all
part of the adventure how do you keep
yourself calm when you know you've been
waiting five years there's been a lot of
ups and downs and then it's like okay
it's go time
I'm really good at compartmentalizing
you know avoidance techniques are really
good blame-shifting is always awesome
I'll watch a lot of TV when I'm feeling
nervous I'll just go home I'll lock
myself in my room and stay up all night
watching you know design shows and
things that are technical and aren't
having to do with the entertainment
business and and you know acting I will
watch design I'll watch fashion anything
but or interviews or not and I read
autobiographies I just an exercise I do
a lot of hiking and you know if things
when all hell makes loose I am up Runyon
Canyon you know connecting with nature
and animals and dogs and
I'm that crazy lady who's chasing after
your dog basically but why isn't it on a
leash I know I know all about that yeah
so but once it's crunch time and you
know that you you have to kind of show
up and be present
are there certain mantras or is there
something that you tell yourself
affirmations absolutely I mean I was
just telling you that I'm about to take
off to do a date with destiny Tony
Robbins I think he's always been one of
my superheroes I came from super humble
beginnings like very poor and left home
early like 15 I ended up getting my
first television series just really by
chance so I got thrust into the to this
universe this world of entertainment
really fast and so I had a lot of
anxiety issues at an early age so I had
to learn all that stuff really young I
think you know meditation and yoga and
all of it found me as a coping mechanism
for a lot of anxiety being thrust into
this world so quickly
so Tony Robbins definitely all his CDs I
would do all the breath work you know
walking right in firming and you know
he's really he's really been the savior
for me as well as so many like Louise
hey and and so many I even even Shirley
MacLaine's books and Deepak Chopra I
mean I'm just an avid reader of
self-help so I think those are really
good in yoga meditating in yoga and
having like a really good core of solid
friendships do you think that an actor
producer filmmaker should always have
another interest that has nothing to do
with the industry to ground them
absolutely but do we have a time for it
probably not I mean no absolutely I mean
travel from me is a savings race I
basically sacrificed my whole 20s to
succeed in this business I really felt
that my time had to be very directed at
what I wanted to do what I wanted to
achieve so I feel like my youth was kind
of sacrificed for this business
I really didn't travel I didn't have
a family like I didn't you know going
out and party like everyone did I was
really learning and focusing and
studying with the best instructors and
and being at every audition and I just
wouldn't do any of that so the minute I
hit my 30s is when I first tried all my
first drugs and not a lot of drugs but
just even recreational things that
everyone has tried
I waited well into my 30s mid thirties
recently to try everything to travel the
world to you know really just get out of
that control freak mentality because
I've really very controlling over my
life and so I've learned to like loosen
up and have some fun and so travel
everything travel adventure for me is
kind of my solace
so I leave like every December January
do you feel like this is your childhood
now I do I really feel that I'm living
that I mean I have so much
responsibility I've taken on so much
responsibility like you were saying
before that whole thing about being a
type and do you keep yourself busy on
the side I have a very flourishing
vacation rental business so I have like
ten properties where I received people
from all over the world and help them
enjoy holidays for less and so that also
takes up a lot of my time but you know
we need our bread and butter sometimes
when these things get slow so I get to
really realize the travel stuff through
people who are traveling to my locations
and so I also get offered these
wonderful like trips and exchanges to
Australia and you know China and places
that you know people wouldn't have
access to it's been a real gift when you
were first coming to LA and and and
getting on a show and and may be very
vulnerable what are some of the things
that really helped you before you found
meditation that's a really powerful
question I think this is this is really
important because I know that so many
people start I almost me get really
emotional talking about this because I
was really alone
and so so a lot of crazy things happen
you know when you're a single girl in
Los Angeles I talk to beautiful thank
you very much and and I was performing a
lot I'm also a musician and I had five
record deals as well I was with Randy
Jackson from American Idol Tommy Mottola
and Donny Hyder so I got a chance to do
all that as well and some scary things
happened early on so I would say yes I
really found I had to I had to even
though I I really disconnected myself
from people I had to really find support
through friendships through through
mentorship I was blessed enough to be
asked to perform and act in Aaron
Sorkin's one of Aaron Sorkin's shows I
met him and he said something to the
effect of like you're the modern-day
female Bruce Springsteen of our
generation and that just really changed
my world getting to do music and acting
in you know one series and that's kind
of what I've always wanted to do so he
after after we the show was canceled he
and I built a really strong friendship
and he really became one of my strong
mentors between him and Randy Jackson
because he was my ANR guy I think those
two were kind of like the dads I didn't
have and so if I had questions about the
business or or scary things came up I
was able to go to them and say what do I
do in this situation what do you suggest
so they were both very helpful for me
even with the writing even with you know
who do I take this to what do you think
is this good do i how do i sharpen it so
I I was really lucky I'm gonna even
George Lucas I had some really
incredible mentors that found me and I
guess I had the sense and the
wherewithal to realize the gifts that I
was handed and really sort of embraced
them and and utilize that help because I
really I needed it I did so I was really
lucky lastly if there's someone watching
now let's say that's just getting into
the business and things are really
taking off for the
and and it's a young female how can they
know that a mentor is right for them
because I know that this is a town of
yeah people of many flavors and you'll
never quite know someone's true self
until you know them out a little bit
I've definitely been in that position to
the couch casting couch I've been
definitely vulnerable to that I think as
women we so often especially in this
business we want it so bad that we're
willing to bend our morality sometimes a
little bit bend and sway because the
idea of this might happen or that might
happen I would say it will not happen
never ever ever compromise yourself in
the name of your art just don't do it
period end of story if it doesn't feel
good in your gut
if someone's asking you to do something
that you're not comfortable with do not
do it and guess what you'll be rewarded
if you stick to your guns and your your
moral compass that will lead you to the
right space and place every time I lost
years because I fell off track with that
I was lost I was a kid sometimes I fell
under the you know the the impression of
somebody who I thought had my back and
they really didn't and they were using
me for whatever reasons and that's easy
to have that happen and I've done the
work to forgive myself
about those things but you know those
young girls starting out in this
business just don't do it simply do not
do it there's other ways find great
teachers find great mentors there's tons
of them a lot of times your acting
teachers can really help you by way of
finding the right managers the right you
know there's wonderful casting workshops
like the casting key and these
one-on-one where you can go and actually
meet great agents and and just do not
ever pay when someone says that you have
to pay to play you have to pay to have
an agent you have to pay to be in it's
it's wrong listen to your instinct our
instincts are powerful mine has never
steered me wrong couple times when I was
in the lower side of my career a couple
times and you just pick yourself up heal
yourself find some interesting
modalities to get back on your feet and
and just don't compromise that's that's
been my strongest message I would say as
an actress as a as a woman in this
industry just do not compromise and a
lot of this whole business is based
around compromise so you know I think
the stronger you can remain in your
voice and be true to the authentic self
that's where your gold is that's where
your platinum is